for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university in the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
so at this point I'm hoping you're
beginning to notice that elements in the
same group have similar electron
configurations and I kinda want to touch
on that in this video the group AAA
elements the noble gases which are right
here kind of pulled that up over here
all of their orbitals are completely
filled with electrons in fact all of
them except helium the first one up here
all of them have an outer configuration
of NS two and p6 helium doesn't have the
NP six it's just ns2 and because they're
completely filled their orbitals they
are very stable they are very stable and
they're not reactive chemical reactivity
is based on what's going on with
electrons and because these things are
filled they're really really stable and
unreactive the group 1a elements the
alkali metals including hydrogen as well
they have an outer configuration of NS 1
and they are very reactive in fact they
tend to form a plus one eye on all of
them and that that's specifically a
cation cations are positive ions so H
forms an eye on to become H+ Li forms li
+ na forms na plus potassium k plus so
for them why they do that is because
losing one electron gives them a
completely filled or stable noble gas
configuration okay and so they all have
similar reactivity because of their
similarity in their electron
configuration
the group 2a elements the alkaline earth
metals they have an auto configuration
of ns2 and they are somewhat reactive
they're pretty reactive I just say
somewhat relative to the alkaline metals
because they're super reactive they tend
to form a plus two ion also a cation is
positively charged so like mg 2 plus c
a2 plus so on and so forth for them if
they lose those two electrons they have
a completely filled and stable noble gas
configuration okay which is why they
tend to form that I on the group 7a
elements the halogens they have an outer
configuration of NS two and p5 and they
are very reactive they tend to form a
minus one ion which is an anion anions
the term applied to negatively charged
ions so fluorine we become f- CL minus
BR minus i minus and for them they're
one electron away from having a perfect
double gas configuration but they have
to gain an electron so they gain one
they gain a negative charge and that
gives them a completely filled stable
noble gas configuration so that's the
ion they tend to form now on your own I
would encourage you to give the outer
configurations of the group 58 group six
elements try that on your own and
describe the ions you'd imagine them to
form that might be a good exercise to do
on your own but I can hope I hope you
see that these things have similar
chemical reactivity because chemically
in terms of the electron configurations
they're very similar hope that video is
helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
Like comment subscribe and share with
friends thank you and happy studying